yeah yeah awesome
hello everyone
um welcome to Pi data day one
um real quick I'd just like to point out
Sarah a member of our code of conduct
team if Sarah could stand up please
awesome Sarah's in the back
um the code of conduct team is just a
resource and helps um kind of protect
and make this community really welcoming
so um if you have any questions or
concerns feel free to reach out to Sarah
and with that I will introduce
uh our next speaker
our next speaker is Lucas Durand Lucas
is the head of data science engineering
at TD Securities and today Lucas will be
walking us through the process of
developing an interactive Network graph
awesome thank you so much
uh hey everyone it's nice to be here and
uh good morning it's first thing in the
morning
um and yeah thanks for coming out
breakfast is outside perfect so yeah
today I'm going to talk about
understanding people with network graphs
in Python
um before I have some slides to start I
apologize uh but we will look at them
um but before we start
um I also in the the schedule for the
event I put a link to a website that has
like an outline for this it has links to
Jupiter notebooks
um some links directly to like code
spaces so if you're uh wanting to follow
along which I recommend I say jump on
that
um it should look like something like
this it's at my website so there's some
stuff copied right from the right from
the page and then some links to
different things there's links to what
we're trying to build as an end result
which would be neat and then yeah launch
it in binder launching code spaces clone
it and uh install the repo locally so
you can follow along the way we
structured it is there are workbooks
that have kind of like
what we're trying to do but stripping
out some of it so you can be a part of
it you can write in a couple lines of
code to make it all work and it's also a
solution so if you really have no idea
what's going on you can just follow
along there and run the code and
customize it as well a lot of it we're
going to touch on just fundamentals and
then hopefully you can take that and you
can customize it you can add more to it
as you go awesome so let's start with
these slides that I promised awesome so
I kind of said what we're going to do
today intro creating graphs next we're
going to get into a more like
complicated thing where we're trying to
add attributes into a graph and then
visualize that as well and then we're
going to build an app which is what we
promised there will be no conclusion I'm
sorry this slide is out of date
okay
uh awesome so who am I I'm Lucas Duran
my pronouns are he him his uh my
background is I was a theoretical
physicist for some amount of time uh and
then I moved into the financial space
and I was a quantitative developer
mostly building low latency algorithms
for pricing uh fixed income instruments
and then I moved to the data science and
software engineering space and since
then the last six or seven years I've
been with TD Securities building out
Jupiter notebooks python analytics
platform log in do your analytics uh
enjoy it right
um and so that's all very exciting my
instrument of choice is the saxophone
mostly the tenor sometimes the berry uh
unfortunately I don't have it with me
today or else we could have had a
totally different talk uh with music
involved and then I love python
um also I work with TD Securities which
is the capital Market side of TD Bank
which is growing in the United States
right now but we're a toronto-based bank
where I'm from if you're interested in a
job talk to me I'm obligated to say that
all right uh that's how I got here today
awesome so let's ground the talk today
in a bit of a problem statement so if
you've ever worked for a big company
especially one that doesn't have a
robust like Network graph solution
already in place it's your first day you
might know what you're working on
hopefully you might have a little like
wiki page that says here your onboarding
instructions and you might know who you
work for and you might have met them
which is great but beyond that it's kind
of hard to know who your other people
are who are your peers in the
organization and that's something that
we're going to try and solve Network
graph so a lot of the times you might
have a kind of half-baked solution
here's an example of something that may
or may not be from my organization which
is now outdated but uh maybe you have a
view of like who's on your team who
reports to you which is great but we
kind of knew that already you might know
who else reports to your manager which
is great this is your like wider team
and maybe you can start to Traverse this
and find out other people but usually
there's a pagination problem going on
it's not really clear who's really close
to you and this is just reporting
structure so there's a lot of places
where this breaks down so a lot of
organized stations report based on
Project teams and so anyone who's not on
your project is hard to find
capabilities are sometimes another
reporting structure so maybe you're in
an Engineering Group and it's great you
know other Engineers but it's not really
clear who's worked on similar projects
or who has similar interests that sort
of data is not not really captured right
and finally especially in the data and
analytics space it's really really
typical to have embedded data scientists
or embedded data analysts which is
essentially saying like
um I'm I'm a I'm a data scientist and
I'm the only one on my team right so who
else do I talk to maybe there's a
community group that exists and maybe
that was part of your onboarding
instructions and that would be great but
if there's not how do you find these
people how do you build communities
right so
um basically what's the org chart plus
we want to take the org chart which
shows you like who you work for and
where you fit uh and try to extend that
by adding more attributes finding new
ways to connect to people
okay so
um before we dive in what are network
graphs uh I don't want to go entirely
into it besides the fact that number
graphs are like a mathematical object
they have some rules and properties and
especially if we're using it um and the
algorithms associated with graphs and
graph Theory there's a lot of powerful
things we can do once we represent data
in the structure so there's yeah there's
three things we want to talk about one
is the graph itself it's made up of
objects the objects can be connected to
each other and they can also hold like
attributes or data so an easy way to
think about it is like a graph is a
bunch of uh like dictionaries and then
there's some other rule that Maps the
dictionaries together right or they're
like some sort of linked object right
the actual objects inside of it we call
nodes other people might call them
vertices or points but I like nodes and
the nodes contain attributes
um that's that's what a node is and then
finally edges connect nodes together
edges can be directed so like they can
point in One Direction only or they can
point in both directions in more
complicated graphs you can have multiple
edges between any two points sure and
then they can also have weighting to
them which is like an importance or if
you think of them which we will later as
Springs it's like how springy they are
and that's it that's that's Network
graphs
um so if you're satisfied you can leave
now but you can stick around and we'll
do more as well
cool so if we actually want to create a
graph the simplest way to start with
this is to say nodes are people right we
just load all our people data into there
and then we say edges are the management
structure and what we end up with if we
draw this is probably what you've
already seen before which is like a tree
representation of an organization or a
reporting structure
and so it should look familiar like we
have this fellow David Chapman who is a
made-up person and they have a lot of
people reporting to them so all those
lines are going up into David Chapman
right and similarly we can start to see
Amy Todd over here sort of near David
Chapman and James Chan is near Amy Todd
and if we're actually looking at that
old view of the org this is a number of
pages away because we have to go from
James Chen to David Chapman up to
someone off screen we can't see back to
Amy Todd and so we have some like
degrees of connectivity here that's
easier to see let me visualize it with
this simple graph so this is a pretty
good org chart I think everyone should
have this at least but I also think we
can do better
um so how do we do better let's
introduce those new attributes so
there's a paper link down here that's a
really good overview of this approach
but essentially the idea is to use the
power of the graph itself and introduce
variables attributes that are already in
the nodes
and then have that influence how the
graph structures itself so there's lots
of ways to like look at connectivity
here here in this like pretty messy
arguably pretty messy looking graph we
added some things in so here you can see
like typescript python Java JavaScript
these are programming languages
um
obviously and then we also have it's
kind of hard to see but the bottom UTC
and so in this graph we added time zones
and we added uh programming languages
and every person in the graph is
associated with these as well so you
could see like UTC connects to a number
of different people but not everyone and
then yeah python Java typescript exactly
right these are all connected to
different people and then the sort of
magic that we can do with the graph is
to use uh like a physics simulator and
to treat all of the nodes as objects
being pulled together by Springs and
being uh
repulsed by each other and allow a
physics engine to do what we call a
force directed layout and to solve the
equation to an equilibrium where
um basically like similar points will
end up pulling closer to each other so
in theory and this is an approach we're
going to take we should be able to build
a graph add in these attributes allow it
to solve itself and then we'll have
these like regions or neighborhoods
starting to emerge from the graph where
similar people are together and I think
in this one uh the colors of people are
based on teams they're on
and so we do see some like team mixing
happening which we wouldn't have seen
before in the earlier graph where
essentially teams are all isolated
together in little groups but here
they're being pulled and pushed together
by similarity of like both both using
python or like both being in the same
time zone despite the fact that their
team might be split across different
areas awesome so what we want to do at
the end of this is to build an app where
we can explore this more share this with
other people maybe it's part of your
company onboarding or maybe it's just
part of a how you try to understand how
people are related or connected and so
what we want to do is use a library
called cytoscape cytoscape is the
JavaScript library in order to build out
a this this graph that you can tweak the
attributes and variables that we want to
look at maybe a color and style it on
the Fly and maybe give it to someone who
doesn't know Python and doesn't want to
go through the notebooks
um but we'll also have all the steps
getting there some other notes is like
as we add more and more things it's
going to get messy it looks pretty big
but this is kind of like a neat look at
what it could look like as an end goal
we see different clustering and clumping
happening this is kind of neat you can
also see the graph is arranged itself
with a lot of these um
like big identifiers like these are apps
and programming languages so there's
like uh JavaScript but then there's also
Tableau and they're all on the outside
pulling nodes into different areas and
so that's that's how we're getting these
clumpings happening
um
yeah
um oh yeah and then lastly there's more
things we can do with graphs as well
um so typically they're used for a lot
of different purposes the one on the
left is showing like API dependencies
and so apis depend on other apis which
depend on other apis it's like that's a
very common way to use Network graphs
not just for people and on the right we
have a similar thing with reporting
structure but we represent attributes
with like colored circles so there's a
couple ways to approach it we're going
to go with making that big messy graph
and then solving it and trying to see
how it looks
awesome that's all I wanted to talk
about for slides now we can actually
jump in and do some python which I think
is exciting uh so yeah if you haven't
yet
um you can go to the site and we're
going to start with uh the data section
we're going to generate some data
um in order to do this typically you'd
start with some like nice clean data
from your organization or from a
community all filled in but we don't
have that I can't give you hours and so
what we're going to do is use a cool
Library called Faker to generate a
population of sample people and then
we're going to use some other libraries
to try and fill it out a little bit more
and we're going to get this like nice
population of people after that we can
load them into a graph then we can add
those clustered attributes and then we
can start to play around with it with
the plotly dash and cytoscape in order
to visualize it interactively
awesome so definitely grab the workbook
I think this link workbook here opens it
to like a GitHub code space or it's
close to a code space you can click a
button and get the code space
um that's what we'll do awesome I'm
going to switch over now to vs code cool
let's just get full screen as well
cool so people what are they how can we
represent them in a meaningful way uh so
like I mentioned we don't have real data
with us so we want to start making some
data that looks real uh so a cool python
library for generating fake data or
sample data is Faker there you have good
docs
um basically the way that it works is
that
you provide it uh or you you ask it for
different it has these things called
providers let's start there and they
provide different kinds of data it also
has a concept of locales and so
depending on what like Locale you
register it in it'll generate different
kinds of data this is cool because we
don't always have everybody showing up
in the United States we don't always
have people in North America or the
western side of the world and so being
able to have locales and generating data
that looks more like that data is really
powerful it also means that if we wanted
to we could use these locales to talk
about like for us we're going to
generate like a company profile and we
can make different company profiles if
we wanted to like big company googly
company microsofty company right with
different rules about how people work
and how they're connected cool so uh the
first thing we can do
um which I suggest you do is uh Faker uh
has this profile provider and this is
combining a lot of their different
providers together but it's a kind of
view of like what a person looks like
um or like a kind of cookie cutter
person uh so we can take a look at this
and start to play around with it so this
person is a recycling officer that's
cool they work for a company they have a
Social Security number it looks like
they live in um
I actually don't know where this is but
uh interesting
um they have a blood group a lot of this
information potentially not really
relevant to us
um although like maybe we want to
introduce people in our company to other
people with the same blood type but I
really don't see a purpose for that it
seems like a recipe for disaster in the
HR department
um and we have names and uh sex and
their address which is different than
their residence because this is very
random so like maybe this isn't exactly
what we need out of the box but it's
something right
um cool other things Faker does if we're
just playing around with it here is we
can ask for Unique values so uh it'll
keep track of what random uh values have
been chosen so far and if we want we can
ask for just unique values so here I'm
going to like Loop through and get all
the prefixes out from the random prefix
and I can run that and it'll go I get uh
all of them out here but I'm enforcing
this uh condition that they'd be unique
each time
um and so I get to the end of the list
essentially and then I'm sad because
there's no more prefixes right not a
very good use case for prefixes which uh
presumably
well one don't really matter but uh they
uh you know we'd have duplicates of this
across a larger population it would be
interesting but potentially strange to
have like a unique representation of
prefixes for everyone in the company and
to just have what is this like eight
people in a company that would be an
interesting hiring strategy okay
so let's uh try to generate a couple
people now and see if this profile makes
sense right
so we can go in here and uh generate a
couple profiles
um
maybe 10 of them and so
it's it's interesting
um we definitely have different people
this maybe is obvious based on the
conversation so far but we have a
geochemist and a Heritage manager and uh
Sandra I don't know what Sandra does um
because you know the output was
truncated but maybe maybe we should
limit the options for these things like
there's a lot of job titles here that
maybe aren't in our company and people
are all over the place as well so what
we could do is is to try and establish
like what are the roles that we should
have in a company where people should be
maybe we pick a couple different offices
and then uh if we really wanted to do it
we could also say like certain teams or
like lines of business are only in
certain regions or they're in different
regions and then that gives us something
that like kind of looks like a real
company okay before we do that we looked
at Faker we decided maybe Faker doesn't
do what we want out of the box but
what's great is we can register new
providers in Faker and use all the
functionality that's built into it which
is mostly like drawing random things and
then potentially using this unique
function as well
um cool but we can register new
providers so if we wanted to register a
new provider for say employment status
we could do that and so I can import
this Dynamic provider and I can say like
let's call this thing employment these
are the options for it and then we'll
just like uniformly draw from these when
we're trying to make a cool person a
cool person a random person and then I
register this now when I call fake
employment I get full time and if I ran
it again I'd get Contract part-time
contract right so now we can add this in
and start to build out our person a
little further
um
like I mentioned this one's like a
uniform random distribution which is
neat but not necessarily exactly what we
want so another way we could do this is
we can make a custom provider and so we
can inherit directly from the base
provider class and like build out a
provider around here so in this case
we're doing the same thing with
employment status but I'm like keeping a
dictionary here of what the value should
be and then awaiting so I can do a
random waiting to my draws so in my
company I've decided it's 70 full time
30 contract and then another five
percent part-time so we are a little
overstaffed at the moment but it's still
still a great company to work for please
come work for us
um awesome and then I Define what my
function should be and then here I'm
using a bit of more enter tools which I
really like to get one value from random
choices of this list of statuses so I'm
saying uh with random choices you pass
in a list of what the options are and
then another potential option list of
the weights and so I put in the weights
from the dictionary and the options from
also the dictionary and now when I run
this and this isn't a very good visual
example I should get full time more
often
you could believe me you could also like
run it and then see like Run Run 10 of
them and see maybe it should look like
that we could do that
[Music]
um
you know
look at 10 of these
and uh
a lot of full-timers um but that kind of
makes sense that checks out this isn't a
horribly we didn't break statistics
today
not yet awesome so these are some
building blocks now we want to build
what an actual person looks like so we
want to do a tech focused person they
work for a tech company or a company
with a tech department we'll focus on
that
I kind of try to try to ground this with
some different data structures to just
fill in so that we end up with things
that have the same names at the end of
it but this isn't strictly necessary
I've also just really been playing
around with data classes in Python
recently and I like to use them maybe
more than I need to but I think it's a
neat way to set up a data structure that
has some like strict fields in it so
here we're importing all the data class
stuff I set there's a time zone it's an
enumeration we'll say there's Eastern
Pacific and UTC
we could create this like location that
people are in it should be like a city a
time zone in a country we could probably
automate the creating of that because
cities are always in a certain time zone
or country as long as the city name is
unique eight great
and then yeah we have a person in our
company so we talked about some of the
things that we we like care about for a
person
um so I figure they should have a name
this is some like unique identifier a
hiring date sounds like something that
most people have
um they should have an employment status
this is like the full-time part-timer
contract we just made that uh fake fake
provider so we're good on that front and
then we should have some languages they
should probably know zero to n
programming languages right not everyone
needs to although maybe if we got a
little deep into it we can make sure
that uh nobody has like the developer or
engineer title if they don't know one
language that might be reasonable
um maybe not depends how you're you're
labeling things but we can get like
pretty deep into all the rules that we
want to establish generating fake data
awesome and then everyone needs a
manager that helps us build a reporting
structure and then probably we want to
give people like team title we've said
title and location cool
um so yeah we can make a person here
um and see how it works
um so maybe this person is me
um I know me well
so that's me uh my higher date was uh
sometime in the past
um I don't know it's like 2016.
uh July 1st that seems right uh my
status is full time right
um so this isn't very exciting uh I get
it
um we got python we got Scala
we've got JavaScript that seems good for
now
um and then yeah I'm thinking I just
leave the manager for now because there
aren't any other people for me to refer
to so this could be a problem already
I'm thinking we have to do this in two
passes we have to set up people and then
decide how they report to each other
um and uh yeah my team is uh whatever
like data science uh and then uh my
title is uh whatever head of um
but probably also when we're generating
people we don't want to do it this way
we want to set up base people maybe
where they are geographically and then
decide like what their jobs are based on
that cool okay so we have a person class
now
um so let's reuse whatever we can from
Faker and add some more of our own
Fields
um so I figured we should do this
programming languages thing let's add a
new provider for this
um so I already started it off here we
have python uh like apparently fifty
percent of the people in the company
know python which I think is
really cool maybe we'll keep that in I
want to work there unfortunately where I
work more looks like Java 50 but that's
okay lots of people do front end let's
put in some JavaScript here they don't
have to sum to 100 which is really nice
um don't put Java again
oops go away
cool
so yeah now we can have Java or not Java
maybe maybe we know go that seems like
something we know but less of us know
that uh cool so now we can add this
provider and I can pull out some fake
number of programming languages awesome
and I broke this I did not finish
writing this in cool so just like we did
before we want to pull random choices
right
um our population is going to be what
are the options here so this is like
list languages
right and then the weights are going to
be the values so it's just what we did
before I think we have to call list on
this but
two awesome
um so I did it wrong again
um
maybe this isn't population maybe I was
wrong about that cool so now I'm just
getting one programming language
um that's not super exciting I wish we
would get more uh I think like a person
could have multiple not just one uh so
probably what we want to do is go in
here and add another parameter I think
choices takes a number so K so here k
equals one is the default but I could
also pull out three
three programming languages but probably
I want to pull out like a random number
of programming languages between zero
and something right so I probably want
to like add in a new uh
a new amount of Randomness here right uh
I could think I'm gonna do zero to five
cool so now a person has like some
different number of programming
languages
um
somewhere in this notebook that maybe
has disappeared I think I made a helper
function for doing this uh
I might have inadvertently deleted it
and now it's only in Solutions but uh
oops you can check there but uh
something that I was using in that other
notebook is uh doing like a dynamically
weighted so we can really go nuts with
this and say uh basically do this random
choices for K but then weight it so then
it hits lower numbers more often then we
have some like outlier developers that
know five languages but like 60 or 80
percent know zero one or two like that's
things we might care about maybe that's
useful later but we don't really need to
go like entirely into this I think we
can get a reasonable looking
organization with just this cool so now
we know fake programming languages
um the last thing I was talking about
was let's get like a little little wild
with Team title and location and say
that like certain teams are in certain
areas and certain teams have certain
roles associated with them
um so let's start off and like Define
some dictionary mapping team names to
roles and then say that certain uh
cities have certain teams in them uh so
maybe like our team Title Here is uh
product we have some engineers and a AVP
or something like that maybe throw in
like a VP on the top
um
and then we say Seattle has like a
couple different uh product groups in
them they have product business and
sales that's cool
um so we now like need product uh
business and sales sales probably
doesn't have Engineers so they're
probably like salesperson
product
sales I don't know I don't talk to a lot
of sales people it's okay and then
business uh maybe business is like uh I
don't know associate oops
associate and then uh
Maybe
I don't know director or something like
that that sounds like someone who works
in the business
uh cool so we have these different
things I can add in another maybe you
want like uh devops
um and then we have like engineer or
senior engineer right so we can have
some title overlap and maybe they mean
the same things which is neat
um and then we have allowed teams per
office so here we said Seattle has sales
product and business maybe we say uh our
Toronto office uh has the devops team
and then a bit of the product team but
no business uh and then maybe we have
like London and they have uh sales and
business right
um
so we can write this out we can add this
add to this we can sort of customize it
and tweak it as we go I mean come back
to it as well
uh cool now we we said we Define the
offices as well
okay so we said there's one in Seattle
there's one in Toronto
Toronto is in EST country is Canada
um
London is in
UTC and the country is
uh
GB GB gbr that sounds right
um cool so now we've defined these
different things and basically
the way that this should work is we want
to pick a team for a person so we
generate our person and then we want to
pick a title a team and return like what
that is so put potentially in that order
it seems like
it wouldn't be in that order so how do
we pull out a like not a unique but how
do we pull out a triple uh from these
three different objects so we have Team
titles the map from the like
team name to what the rules are we have
office locations which is a city to the
team names so it looks like the the like
flow pattern here is to go from uh
location then determine a team that
could be there and then determine what
your role is right
um so probably we want to go first and
say like my location equals uh we can
just use the random from fake because I
was too lazy to import it
um random Choice from uh what is this
allowed teams per office
looks like I didn't run this also
uh cool and then
the title is probably uh
random Choice from uh
location uh
right that should be in there and then
the actual team
um
that was team
and then title we could pull from our
team titles thing right cool we are
getting there
we are getting there
title
uh
sweet
um
cool I was a bit lazy here where were
our locations
offices
yeah
I think this is City actually
officer City
title title team cool did that did I
break it
well this part isn't fun anymore
um
you know what let's switch over uh if
you're following along I strongly
suggest you do it's so much fun
um
awesome
cool so we have these uh things that we
just built together right put together
um cool
we have some programming languages we
have some people
um in this one to find like way more
Team titles right we have devops Deva
devx developer experience devops sales
support whatever but the same structure
that was there before
um and then we we took some random
choices this is choose a few is also the
thing I mentioned before which is our
um like weighted uh weighted towards the
bottom Random Chooser cool so now we can
make a person uh it's pretty simple we
get the title team and city for the
person
um which if we looked here should be
like a location titled
right um that all makes sense now we can
create a person this is really exciting
we've generated random people now we
just want to know like does this make
sense
um it seemed to make sense I spoke
confidently that this was a good idea
but we should probably validate that it
makes sense
um anyways we're passing this all into
our data class person which is great and
they know program languages they have an
employment status right they have some
hiring date
um awesome so what we can do is load
this into a data frame because we like
data frames and we can see some people
right so it seems like they have
um
the names and statuses and they know
different amounts of programming
languages which is also exciting we like
that
um now all we have to do is set up their
reporting structure right I think for
some reason I missed this so yeah they
have titles they have locations and they
have teams they just need a manager uh
this is great so we can also get a
little wonky with how we want to Define
managers right our manager is always in
the same city our managers always in the
same team probably let's do that and
then maybe managers should have a title
that's like equal to or greater than
yours probably greater but
um I don't know maybe maybe there can be
like same level reporting as well
um
cool so we can treat that list we made
of titles up here
uh as like uh being you know increasing
in in rank throughout and that'll help
us on that Journey
um and yeah uh so this part if we're
following along it's a little uh wonky I
apologize
um but here we're going to calculate
ranks for different people so we're just
saying like the rank is based on that uh
dictionary of lists so for each of these
different entries in the list we'll say
um we'll take like a account of how many
are in the list and then you know rank
them accordingly so devops like engineer
one senior engineer two and we go up
from there similarly for like product it
goes engineer manager product owner
avpvp right this just helps us sort it
in the future if we wanted to we could
just sort it in pandas as like a
categorical list but I thought this was
a little bit easier now we'll go through
our data frame
and we will go team by team and then
apply those ranks what we should get out
is something a new column called rank
this is just going to help us decide
who's a manager because we say their
rank has to be bigger or the same and
then here's some like wacky pandas code
that I don't want to get too deep into
but basically what we're doing is saying
like we're going to look at some subset
of the data frame so we'll Group by team
and then that'll be like a subset of the
data frame and we're going to look at
filtering it so that you only look at
people who have a greater rank than the
person we're looking at or the same rank
right and then we'll just take the first
one that meets that criteria preferring
someone of Greater rank right and we'll
just plop their name down as the
supervisor
this is also like keeping the Sorting of
the data frame in place so in theory we
should if somebody is of rank five right
they should get picked up by people all
of rank four of the same team so we'll
have a lot of people reporting to the
same person which is kind of vaguely
what we want to do right awesome so we
can run this and it'll go through and
now assign managers to people so that's
it we have our data frame we have our
fake people
um Rhonda Rivas is a contractor started
in 2022 Larry Rubio is their manager
they work on devex or an engineer they
have a location and a rank the rank we
no longer really need but maybe we'll
want to use it later for something
um awesome so
um what we end up having here is uh we
have a lot of team leads at the top so
they don't necessarily have someone to
report to and then we just need to now
hire a CEO
um decide on what their salary is
probably too much and uh then assign all
those like floating people to them so
now we have each of the team leads uh
and probably not multiple team leads but
I didn't really check I know we just
need to set them as the CEO being their
their person so we did that here we made
this CEO with our same make person
function then we overrode some of the
inputs so we said like they should be on
their own team called CEO they're
full-time whatever
we set their location this is like a
normalization thing let's skip that and
then we added the CEO into our data
frame so they're in there now the next
thing we need to do is uh just update
anybody who doesn't have a manager to
report to the CEO which we're doing here
with this location uh statement and then
we can also set some rank for the CEO
because it breaks things later on when
we want to use rank so cool now we have
a CEO there in the company and we should
have everything
um
sort of a
implementation deepdale is we had that
location
[Music]
um
object in our data frame and it doesn't
necessarily play well with everything so
we can flatten that out and make new
columns for each entry in the location
so we're kind of like flattening out our
data frame
um easy way to do that is to like apply
series across the column
it's not super fast but it works for
this purpose uh yeah and then now we can
jump into plotly and take a look and
make broad sweeping statements about
whether this is a good idea or not or
whether it works
um fantastic
uh right so with plotly if you haven't
used it before it has a kind of grammar
of graphicsy interface we can put in a
panda's data frame and then provide
different column names to it and it will
generate and change the way that it's
appearing based on what the values are
in those columns so we could pass in our
data frame here we can say like let's
look at the titles of people
as X we could say I mean I kind of Dove
all the way into this one so we said
let's look at the titles on the bottom
here with X let's color the different
um entries in the bar graph based on the
team that they're on and then I said
let's make facets so it's breaking out
into subplots based on the country that
they're in right and so in this view of
things we have lots of information but I
think like the takeaways here are like
um
if you look at Ireland on the far right
here there's only two teams represented
which is probably what we set up before
but a sort of uh skipped over so there's
a bunch of folks from the devops team
are here they don't seem to be anywhere
else so that's that's probably fine and
then all the folks from support are here
as well which is also probably fine
Canada has a real mix of different teams
I think we set it up that way
I guess the other things are there's
only one CEO so we didn't mess that up
which is good and there's a whole ton of
Engineers maybe too many but maybe this
is just a really engineer Focus everyone
has that title
um
just one managing director that's
probably fine but we can have like does
this look like a company it certainly is
maintaining some of those distribution
effects that we wanted to do right we
have people in different companies teams
in different companies or countries
rather and uh different roles in each
team right potentially
fewer and fewer of the higher level
roles cool
okay so we're going to call this a huge
success we've created sample data but
it's kind of it's leaving some to the
imagination like what does this
organization actually look like in order
to do that I think the best way is to
jump into the next section
which is looking at
uh building a graph and then visualizing
the graph it will become more apparent
when we do that
awesome
let's jump into that
don't don't give it away too soon
um awesome so understanding people now
we can really start doing what we wanted
to do uh so what we're going to do today
with this data is we're going to use
Network X so Network X is an in-memory
graph representation it's written in C
or Fortran or both maybe and so it's
quite fast it's a good way to represent
graphs and it comes with a whole host of
graph algorithms built into it so once
you transfer the way that you're looking
at data into a graph graph first you can
start to answer questions that would be
harder to do using something like a
pandas data frame or just like normal
python objects even doing what we just
did before which was uh assigning
managers based on all these rules would
be a lot easier to do in a graph
representation but you know we weren't
here yet we were still in the first
notebook we didn't know about graphs so
how do they work here's here's the quick
the quick on this they also have great
docs good tutorial that I stole some of
this from so check that out too if
you're sort of lost um so it's easy to
load data in you can add nodes nodes can
have attributes you can pass attributes
as keyword arguments when you're adding
a node like this single node or you
could pass them in as like a dictionary
of attributes which is great and they
typically want a label
um
for us we'll probably use like people's
names but a better idea would use like
their unique identifier like person ID
something like that so yeah we can add a
note in it's me I'm a person I know
python we can also do it from an
iterable so this is you and them
and they have some other languages they
know but we're doing this from like a
an iterable of tuples right with the the
first being like the label and then the
rest being the attributes this is using
the dictionary and we can look at them
so we can look at nodes and we see all
three of them are in there it's in the
graph now me you and them and we can
also get all those attributes out if we
wanted to and it's sort of represented
and can be accessed like a dictionary of
dictionaries which is cool by saying
data equals true and if we wanted to we
could just get out specific attributes
as well by specifying data equals
whatever that attribute is so here we
said languages but we could also say
like
uh what was the other one we did person
and it'll say like
oh sorry type
and type should say like person right
for everyone because we said that and we
made them which is great so we can use
that to filter or to uh iterate through
and get that data back out cool
finally uh to make it really powerful as
a graph we want to add edges and so the
edges will connect to these nodes
together in our case our graph we
initialized is just a regular graph
there's other options as well most
notably a directed graph which is di
graph or Digraph and uh so right now
we're going to add edges but they don't
really Point anywhere but in a directed
graph they can point
um cool so I'm going to connect me and
you and you and them and the edge
connection label is friends so like
we're all friends now well I mean me and
you are friends and you and them are
friends but is there a way we can all
become friends so uh way we can use the
graph is find the shortest path between
nodes it's going to follow those edges
so I could say how do I get from me to
them and it is it's through you so this
is great
we're either all friends or
we know how to connect through our
friendship friendship is bringing us
together
um and there's a couple other
interesting uh features of the graph as
well like we just get all that
connectivity information out through the
adjacency uh
um view of the graph
um and finally we can also visualize
which is fantastic and I apologize for
the white background
um we will fix that later but great like
we can visualize a graph now so in
theory we have all we need to now
visualize this group of people based on
their their connections right we know
how they connect based on management so
let's keep going through that
um great
um I was lazy so let's just reload
everything from the last notebook into
this one
fantastic okay so how do we add nodes
um we need to create a new graph for
ourselves now and then we'll probably
want to iterate over all the nodes and
pass them in and register them in our
graph right
um so it turns out not too hard to do
um we can do that by uh
by making this generator here
there's other ways you can do it of
course but uh I figured dumping our
dictionary into or sorry dumping our
data frame into a dictionary
and then iterating over that and piping
it into our graph was pretty simple one
liner to do that some other ways we'd
want to do that is to maybe look at or
some other things to consider or we're
starting to create nodes like on mass
and we know that later we want to create
other types of nodes and so we might
want to label these nodes in some way
that'll be easy to identify them later
and so
what we did was we added
sorry this is kind of a
we added in uh person flag so person
equals true
for some reason also type equals person
so some redundancy there but
future myself needed it for some reason
and it's here now so now we have
potentially a whole graph of different
people
um and we can get out all the all the
data inside of them
um based on how we did this we actually
embedded both like the name of the
person as the label for the node and
then also the entire
um like row of that data frame that
entire object uh as the attributes
um so if we run this we should get back
people from a graph so Edward Chen is in
here
um he's a person his type is person his
name is here
um and then we get all the other
information as well like the higher date
can I scroll this no not too well the
status part-time language is what they
know right who their manager is Jennifer
French right and their team so our data
is in the graph now
hmm
and now what we need to do is visualize
it that's what we said we were here for
right so awesome as we said before this
is using matplotlib sorry we didn't say
that part before this is what it uses
all we need to do is pass in our graph
to the draw function and we should get
back a graph and here's our beautiful
graph of all the people in our
organization they're all blue blobs and
they're in a big circle
um now this isn't very great it doesn't
really provide us a lot of information
um we haven't connected anybody yet so
we need to add the edges into our graph
and then we should be able to draw this
in a little more meaningful way just
based on how they're they're connected
so
um before that I thought it would be fun
to add some color so the network X draw
feature allows us to provide
um
does it allow us to provide a like node
color argument and the node color
argument is going to let us uh where did
I say this
um it's going to let us provide colors
for each of the notes right we want to
do this based on
some attribute that's already in the
graph so I thought it would be good to
do it by team we know that teams all
report internally right up their
structure to each other and so maybe we
want to we want to look at those and
differentiate teams as well as
individual people so in order to do that
we need to have some way to map teams to
people this is a real fun one so here I
took uh we're using the plotly library I
mentioned which I probably imported at
some point
um and it has a number of different
color scales basically we want to
associate like each unique value from
teams with a color and then we want to
generate that whole big list for each
node and pass that into our draw
function so here we have something uh I
don't know there's a lot of different
color scales you can check out
from from uh
potli Express
um
the qualitative ones are pretty good
because they're designed to represent
like categories but
um if you use something like diverging
the colors will slowly change and which
is not really good at differentiating
fully different things but here yeah we
could use anything I can switch it up
just for fun like dark two sounds
exciting I want to find out what that is
um so that's that's an option for us and
then we want to go through all the
unique values right from our data frame
um
and we should get back like what are the
unique teams these are unique teams
right and then we can pass that in with
our
dark guy here
and we'll get those list of colors
mapping teams to this RGB code which is
what we got from plotly
um
it turns out that's not what uh Network
X wants they want to have hex codes so
here's some like wacky translator
functions and we can get to what we
really want which is this list of like
node colors as uh
node colors as hex codes which is
hopefully what this is
did we miss something here
I think I missed you
fantastic love it
um we were really excited about dark two
but it's not going to do what we need
um so we probably don't want to use zip
here we'd either want to start replacing
or like duplicating colors which is what
a lot of plotting libraries do or
because I don't want to do that right
now we can just switch back to whatever
we're using before which happened to
have enough colors thank you very useful
awesome so now we get the giant list of
colors right we could pass this in as we
make our draw and we can get out a more
exciting diagram
which kind of looks like a poorly
planned Easter egg hunt Maybe
awesome but as I mentioned it really
needs to have edges to pull it all
together so we could do that next
um
the yeah the we can make this part a
little more exciting
um instead of just showing the answer
here but uh it turns out
um
the graph is making it really easy for
us to look and find these connections uh
so when we're defining edges we want to
pass in this iterable saying like each
of the sources to the targets and for us
we could pull out that information
pretty easily by looking at the nodes so
each node in our graph has names right
and if we look at the data including the
nodes what we want to do is find for
each person find out like who the
manager is right and so that information
is inside the node and uh in our little
uh exploration intro to network X we
also saw that we could pull that out
directly using like this data argument
so because a data equals manager and
this is basically just what we need here
this is the sources and the targets and
this is like a big iterable that we can
iterate over and we can just pass it
right into uh or add edges from
um Whatchamacallit add edges from method
on our graph and we can populate this
um based on its notes so pass that right
in and we can similarly give it some
like label like manager manager equals
true we thought that was important
before and then when we draw it it looks
like it looks like something so we've
created an organization
um
probably benefiting the world we could
see that people are reporting into some
Central node that's purple here it's in
the middle and then we have clusterings
right there's there's some folks over
here on some team
um other folks on another team it looks
like some teams with the same colors
have been split up so potentially not
everybody from a team reports to the
same team lead which is good that
doesn't always work that way but it does
look like there's like sub teams all
reporting into our CEO in the middle
which is great
um yeah I think this is a bit of a win
we have something that's vaguely
like organization like it has this tree
structure that we want to see there's
clusterings of people together
um
I think I think at this point we
probably want to like double check that
this makes sense
um this visualization method doesn't
give us a lot of
a lot of
pass-through of information like I don't
really know which team is which I could
look up the colors and figure that out I
don't really know what people's rules
are I'm assuming that it's in the right
order so something a little more
interactive would make this easier to
work with
um great so now we want to switch from
using matplotlib which is great for out
of the box easy Integrations with a lot
of tools and switch to plotly so this is
going to be generating our like
JavaScript based plots and then
rendering those and they'll be nice and
interactive
um so I'll just sort of walk through
this sort of nasty function here but
what we what we want to do is take our
graph which is here and we want to
generate like positions so when we're
calling nx.draw the flow that's
happening is Network X is first taking
all the nodes in the graph and the edges
and then deciding where they should be
in euclidean space and then they're like
creating that so that's called a layout
so the first thing that's happening here
is we're going Network x dot like I like
spring layout because I keep saying
Springs and I want the idea of like
these are things on Springs to go
through but there's a lot a lot of
different ones so we can go spring
layout G and what we should get back is
like uh
uh I guess it's a set no it's a
dictionary and we have each of the like
no names and then their position and
euclidean space right a little XY
coordinate this is great
um
for these kinds of plots the other one
that's really good is a
layout
it's a kamada kawaii layout
um
but of course I didn't install scipy so
uh
that's not here
so that'll chug for a little bit
um
cool but there are different layouts we
can use depending on how much we want
the like physics to go on this the
spring layout is really fast and easy to
use but you might see that a lot of
overlapping nodes whereas something like
the kamada Kawaii or other more complex
layout models we'll we'll like run a
number of iterations and keep other
rules in place to sort of like bounce
nodes around and add in things like
repulsion which is neat
um sci-fi is just going to go forever I
guess uh in one minute it's not that bad
great so the next thing we have our
positions right names and then XY
coordinates
um
plotly wants a data frame
um I mean it doesn't but we like to use
data frames with plotly and so now we
want to construct a new data frame with
the positions but then also all the
information from the graph that we want
to use so here we have a data frame
we're saying that like there's a label
on it which is the label from the node
because I'm getting like key value from
that positions plot
then I'm getting the X and Y coordinates
which are again from that positions uh
that big dictionary that we created
right
um and then here there's like a default
size because nodes need a size and then
we're just dumping in the rest of our
attributes to repopulate this data frame
we probably could have just gone back to
the data frame we already had before and
then put in and merged in the different
uh X Y coordinates with it but
um you know
we're not we're not paying by the uh
line of code here or by the
hour of compute
um awesome so yeah like I said there's
other layouts too we don't have to use
the spring layout
um
there are other options
cool
um cool so there's some more logic in
here uh it turns out we had some sets in
the data frame and plotly doesn't like
sets because they're not hatchable so we
can go through and like convert sets to
lists I think we actually dumped this
out in the implementation earlier but
like there's some nitty-gritty here
um the rest of this is trying to like
pop out different keyword arguments and
pass those through to plotly if they're
plotly arguments that's fine but the the
real uh hero here is we're going to make
a scatter plot we have the X and Y
coordinates right and then we have some
data that we can inject into it based on
the columns that are in our data frame
we can also I don't know like fiddle
around with the x-axis and Y axes so it
looks nice
and then the last thing we want to do is
optionally add in edges as well so we
also have those edges it turns out this
is kind of slow so I made it optional
but uh here we're going to draw this
graph as well so we create our layout
that's great we get our edges
um
we um
this is the same function before to make
the figure of just nodes and then we
want to add on to that the edges as well
cool
um right so here we're adding traces
into our existing uh figure and each of
the traces is a single line This is why
it gets like kind of slow it's a lot of
overhead to create these I didn't think
of a better way to do it if you know one
please tell me please let me know for
the good of mankind all of us cool
um and then here we're sort of shuffling
it around
this part is not super exciting but it
allows us to have a nice and expressive
interactive way of viewing our graph
which is what we do want to do
so what are some things that we want to
do
we want to make sure the reporting
structure makes sense so before we had
some rules about who should report to
who and we want to make sure those are
in place you know we don't want to have
in this case like the CEO shouldn't
report to an engineer or a VP to an
engineer or like sales people and
Engineers shouldn't mix right they don't
talk to each other whatever it is in our
organization that we've set up we want
to make sure that's happening
we want to make sure that the like job
titles make sense there's like
everyone's a VP it doesn't really make
sense sounds like a financial firm
um okay you get it
um and we want to say the locations make
sense we did have rules about who should
be in what location and we're pretty
sure that worked based on a
the borrower chart that we looked at
before but it would be good to to look
at that in action too and as I mentioned
the with edges piece is a bit expensive
we could try toggling it off if you find
it bothersome
um great
okay so
um okay and I also introduced here we're
just sneaking in new new features all
the time we could also customize the
layout so before we mentioned it was
using a spring layout if you really
wanted to you could Sub in here
um
could change like the function that's
being passed in you could do that
commodity Kawaii layout which I think is
pretty cool and it looked like it
actually only took a couple seconds
which seemed like an Infinity when I was
running this a million times trying to
tweak it but uh probably not a big deal
now it's working
um great so now our plot function should
look a lot like uh plotly Express plot
function and that we pass in a data
object right this is a graph instead of
a data frame and then we Define what
attributes of that data structure we
want to use to to generate the
appearance right so we say like the
attribute country should determine the
color of the nodes in the graph
this is the layout and then we say with
edges equals false so I can run this a
couple times we could choose then like
what's the name that comes up when I
hover over a node we can decide what are
the size of the nodes based on for us
there's only really one column that
helps for this and it's the rank that we
made before but you could also do things
like make calling based on like salary
or years with company or something like
that a numerical value and then we can
make the nodes bigger or smaller based
on that that might help visually to see
um
yeah that would be interesting to see
that actually would be a cool thing to
add in and then we can also pass through
like what the template should be
um so it doesn't burn your eyes we can
use a dark uh view of this so yeah this
is what we get out from it
um
we have this person in the middle Kelly
flowers
um who's Irish or they live in Ireland
uh they are the CEO
um I'll run this with the with edges
just so you can see that too
um like I mentioned it takes some
really horrendous amount of time to run
um
almost seven seconds uh terrible but now
we can see that view so this is the same
structure we had before it even is using
the same layout which isn't
deterministic but we get that same sort
of feel from it there's this like
interesting cluster of folks here
um so they appear to be
um what are they like a mix of
contractors and full-time
manual programming languages excuse me
but this is the devx team right there
are all devx folks they're all engineers
and they're all in the USA I believe
they're all in Fort Lauderdale on our
example
um a growing Tech hub
uh awesome
um yeah and so we also based uh rank as
the size and so in theory we should see
the circles getting smaller as we go
further out from the graph right which
we kind of see the biggest ones in the
middle these guys are getting smaller as
we go out
um and then you know we have these
coloring clusters which makes sense but
this is a nice way for us to explore and
actually visualize the data that's uh in
the nodes which we weren't doing so well
with the network X like default view we
could have put some more effort into
that matplotlib would allow us to like
customize that but it wouldn't allow us
to make it interactive in this way
um so I couldn't like zoom in and see
that this team here which is uh sales is
pretty diverse across countries they're
in whatever this is Canada Great Britain
and the USA
uh sales love them okay awesome and then
we could also uh tweak this and look at
other things so what is this one this is
looking at actual teams so this is
closer to the view we had before where
all the reporting structures should be
like all the same color because they're
all on the same team reporting up so it
looks uh vaguely like we did what we
wanted to do this is a good
representation of an org
um
I don't know um it would be a cool extra
at this point to like go back tweak the
teams and the structure and the rules
and then keep coming back and looking at
this and then we have like a sample data
generator and uh a visualizer for the
organization that's creating which we're
excited about
we're super excited
um awesome so this is great
um we can move on now
uh and what we want to look at next is
uh basically what we said this whole
time was what we wanted to do was we
wanted to build this org with random
people spend a lot of time making random
people people are hard and then what we
want to do is now add new nodes to the
graph just based on attributes that
people have
and so this follows the same pattern we
did before
um
but it's it's useful to sort of look at
what we're doing here just to hammer at
home we don't need you on the side there
so we're using some more little funky
stuff that I like enter tools is fun if
you don't know it's a built-in and more
editor tools mostly just implements the
recipes from the docs in itter tools
which is also great
um I advocated to become one of your
standard libraries just stick it in on
every project saves you rewriting the
same code for like get the first value
of this or like
um always iterable means that I can
always Loop over something
um even if it's just a single value
instead of you know
you always run into that issue where
you're looping over a string and you
just get out the individual elements of
the string horrible right
um this solves that problem it's great
so we made a little function here it's
add nodes from attributes we give our
graph we tell it the attribute name and
what it's going to do is it's going to
go into each node so we're going to
iterate over those nodes in the graph
which we can show above here so say we
wanted the attribute of Team
the default part's not super important
and now we're getting each person and
the team that they're on right
and so that's what this line is doing as
long as there is an attribute we're
getting out all the attributes of that
person or sorry the person and that
attribute it could be a list if it was
our languages attribute as well that's
sort of why reason is always iterable
thing then what we're doing is getting a
unique
um a new unique values for all of these
I think we could also just done like I
don't know like set this dot values but
maybe this doesn't have a DOT values
uh yeah it appears not to so you know
we'd have to make it a dictionary first
which is what we're doing in the uh dick
comprehension here uh so we're making
this a map and then we're finding the
unique values because what we want to do
is take all the unique values from our
graph of this attribute so if it's a
team we'd want to get business sales
devops devx and we want to put those in
as notes so I won't be legal the point
too much more but we Loop over that
using a great number of wacky functions
and then we add those nodes in and so
when we're adding them in we're saying
add in a new node with the name business
or devops or python right and then add
in these flags as well the flags are
very important it gets confusing now
that we have different kinds of nodes in
the graph we don't want to treat people
the same way that we treat python
because they're not the same kind of
thing
um awesome so we can do that for a
couple different things we can add nodes
from attributes for languages and give
it some Flag
City
and give it some flag TZ for time zone
um
not entirely important that we make the
flags different but it could cause
trouble later depending on how we use it
but right now we have new nodes in the
plot and the graph in theory if we took
like a quick look at it with our PX plot
and XG thing
um
I probably needed to pass in one of
these things like color equals uh
team but it doesn't like that
yeah
um you know we have we have the same
plot we had before
um
just a little hard on the eyes
yes but we've now added in new um new
little uh what should we call it new
notes right so they just popped up here
based on the logic of our other plots so
we have like the languages now so we
have
um typescript Java erlang right so it
found those and now we have those nodes
in the graph this is great this is what
we wanted now we need to connect the
edges so we can do pretty much the same
thing we did but did before with manager
and the same sort of structure that we
used just before to add the nodes in in
order to Loop through find all the
unique attribute nodes and then connect
people to those notes so here we're
finding uh what is it
um this is well we're here at the way to
filter a graph so we can get a sub graph
that um meets a certain filter
requirement right so we defined here
just people as a filter
basically it goes over each node in the
graph and then it runs this on it and so
it says like if uh if the node that's in
that graph at that key is has this
person flag we keep them if not we throw
them away we don't want to I think it's
mostly to avoid errors and there's
implementation but
we don't want to like python doesn't
code JavaScript right I mean it kind of
does in that plotly right now that we're
using is using JavaScript but I think
that would be like a strange thing to
add into our graph it might complicate
things although I'm kind of interested
in it now that I've just said it
um awesome
um
cool so that we could go in and do that
for edges as well right
so now we have languages let's add time
zone and City and then when we look at
this we should get something
um
I guess this is that
that looks like our team structure but
it's been it's been warped now so we
have not just people being arranged by
how they're reporting but they're also
being arranged
um being pulled and pushed right by each
other and these new things language City
and time zone so it'd be useful here to
did I have one with edges no
it would be useful to run this with
edges but this will take longer
but now we should be able to see teams
that are on so we can still keep that
but what we should see is teams starting
to mix now some some of the things that
might hamper that when we're looking at
the plot
um
is the fact that we have some overlap
between teams because we made team
derivative of country and like time
zones related to Country and roles are
related to teams right so we might have
some like carry over there but what we
should see is especially in this area
um
oh so that's time zone but we have folks
from the
anyways it's no longer nice tight
bundles of people from the same team
there are other factors that are now
pulling them and causing them to mix
around right
um so this is all just based in the
graph
um we focused a bunch on making the
visualization but really like the logic
and the intelligence is all in the graph
and when we assembled the graph it was a
couple lines of code right like we just
pulled in the people out of the edges we
had this New Logic in order to figure
out how you deal with attributes that
aren't people so we flag them in a
different way we can we can separate
them and look at them
um but now we have this like more
complicated graph but maybe Paul Ray and
Catherine those uh should get to know
each other they're both people
um
Catherine's on the product team Paul's
on the platform team but uh
what is it do they know languages
neither of them know any languages so
that's great you know uh
great example that one just came out um
I have a bunch of extra things that you
might be interested in if you want to
follow down there's some other parts of
network X that allow us to like from
this point just identify what
communities there are algorithmically so
one is an ego graph you can do an eagle
graph around a node and it returns to
like a sub graph of people that are
connected within X steps or like within
a certain radius depending on how you've
set up your edges for us you could set
that like radius equals two and that
would return to you anybody
who was either connected directly to
your manager right or to someone that
reports to you so like that's the one
too or anyone that goes through a point
like python so then my new like ego
graph is like anybody that knows the
same languages is in the same country
right so that's like one way we could do
it it's kind of naive it doesn't take
into account how these other attributes
are connected uh so like you would lose
the fact that lots of people that know
python also know uh
JavaScript and then maybe I want to be
closer with those people just based on
the fact that people who know this also
know this these communities are more
tightly related than maybe
um or erlang and JavaScript right but
that wouldn't necessarily come out with
this naive approach but that's something
we can do
um you can also use this all pairs node
connectivity and it gives you a big dump
of like a matrix of all these things
um another way we could do it is we can
make the spring layout and then
calculate what the positions are and
then do like a euclidean distance
between all the different pairs of
points and then I can make some Rule and
draw a circle so this takes into account
this is basically what we're doing
visually we're rendering the graph and
then we're looking at an area and saying
like this makes sense this is similar
and we're letting the physics do the
work and then finally
uh okay so that's the physics doing the
work
um
cool but it's uh really the same
approach in Spirit uh to representing
the graph in more than two Dimensions uh
and then doing like a distance metric
between them as well so our layout right
now is set to two Dimensions because
it's a lot easier to view but if you use
a library like node direct algorithm
like node devec we can take this graph
and it'll dump it immediately into like
n dimensional Vector space and then you
can look and see like what's close to
what
um that's great it also plays well with
pipetting something like a k-means
clustering or like other typical
clustering algorithms that you would do
um in Vector space which is like a well
trod path so we can get our graph there
and then it's easy to determine
communities there's a few other
algorithms in network X including in the
communities module that are great for
that as well and I have some like links
to them all in the docs but we don't
really have time to get into that today
okay so in the last couple minutes uh we
want to get to actually building the
interactive app right
um so let's jump into that so what we
want to do is use uh Dash so if we're
not familiar with Dash
it is a python based library that wraps
around sorry about that wraps around
react and uh flask and it'll generate
little apps so here's an example of a
Dash app really simple one
um we have a layout this is like the
wireframe for the app and everything is
these HTML objects and they are
surprisingly the same as HTML objects in
HTML HTML HTML so here we have a little
header we have a paragraph with
something in it and then a button the
other intricacy to this is we Define
callbacks and this is rules for what
happens when something changes so here
we wrote a rule and we said when the
input which is this button when the N
clicks property which is the number of
times has been clicked changes we should
run this function update Title on button
click and the return value from this
function should be piped into this the
output so title children
so this is a great way to I don't know
it works this is how Dash works so if we
ran this app what we're saying is that
yep so the output is the title which is
this asimple app header and we're saying
that it should be changed to this value
when the button click happens and so
really quickly we can look at that this
is our app right
it is a simple app and when I click this
something happens right fantastic so now
we have a mechanism in Python to expose
our graph and we just need a way to
visualize it and then we have a lot of
different components that we can use to
interact with it change the values maybe
redraw it maybe color it differently
what we were doing manually with plotly
but now we can do in a way that we can
expose to users or just generally do
without messing around with code the
other thing that's interesting about
Dash is we can also make it a bit more
complicated and looking a bit nicer
using bootstrap there's a couple
different Frameworks not just bootstrap
Mantine is another really popular one
that you can use with Dash that are
wrapped up into it but essentially now
we're doing the same thing you would do
with a bootstrap app
with DPC instead of HTML and we can
Define all the elements in here so
um yeah generally I don't have much to
say about this other than layouts
usually you make a container you put
rows in it there's columns that's
bootstrap and and then you can do things
like here's our headers and inputs and
uh we can have different inputs for
things so this app is pretty simple it
unfortunately lints into a kind of wild
structure here but what we're doing is
we're going to have a little callback
where we generate new paragraphs and
that's something you could run with like
um yeah generally paragraphs let me
change the way it works based on
based on uh
the inputs
I appear to have broken it
oh fake is not defined um
we uh did not run the cell that comes
after this
which is a reasonable thing to do
okay
um
cool cool cool
so
now we can run this bootstrap app which
is not the main event but
um it just has random code or sorry
random text but now we have like it's
kind of nicer looking we could spend a
lot more time making this nice but I'm
right I'm I'm changing things and it's
altering things python code is running
right I can increase the number of
sentences that are in it
um awesome so this is all we need to
build our interactive app this is the
framework for it
um now all we need to do is take our
um
take our graph and uh
make elements that cytoscape likes so if
we read the docs for cytoscape it turns
out it wants something in the format of
uh
like a dictionary of uh or a list of
dictionaries where we have the elements
and they should have data in them
and other attributes right it turns out
Network X oops a network network X plays
with this very well we can just generate
the the format that we need from it and
it's going to dump out the graph
represented for cytoscape
so the graph itself doesn't have data
but it does have elements and the
elements are like nodes and there's a
data element in it and it has these
things all dumped out so this makes it
pretty easy for us we can pipe this
right into cytoscape and it'll be happy
it also has information about like
whether the graph is directed or it's a
multi-graph meaning there could be
multiple edges uh
between the same two points
um not really important for us but that
makes that part easy
and all we do in this function here
create graph is bundled together some of
the logic from the last couple
notebooks that we worked through so now
we're making this directed graph we're
adding the nodes from people right just
adding the nodes and then we're going to
allow it as a function to pass in a list
of attributes and then we'll Loop
through and do that attribute node and
Edge thing that we were doing before
um fantastic so pretty simple logic it's
boiling down a lot of what we've done in
the past hour and a bit into an
embarrassingly small amount of code
um but really like we don't have to
revisit that again now we just want to
focus on like tweaking this adding new
stuff and then being able to explore the
graph
um right and then lastly for creating
elements we're just taking the nodes and
the edges from that dump from Network X
and putting it into a big list together
we just put them all in together
fantastic
awesome the last piece that we could
spend a lot of time on is cytoscape will
render all the nodes
using a layout so we'll provide that
later but then it Styles all the nodes
using a style sheet and the way that we
Define this is using a list of
dictionaries here but we create
selectors and the selectors will look at
the values of or the types of the nodes
and objects in the graph and then it'll
also potentially look at the the data
inside of it and then style things
differently this is all going to be
happening on the JavaScript side which
makes it pretty quick
also limiting if we're like really
scaling the size up but here we're going
to do some basic stuff like say nodes so
this is any node we should say it should
have a certain font size and a certain
color right we could say the same for
edges there's lots to customize here if
you go into the cytoscape JS docs you
can
all that copies over here
and then we can do some more customized
stuff based on the values we're
expecting so we're going to say any Edge
that has languages equals true that's
what this means in its data is going to
have a label on it and we're going to
define the label here we could also do
this more generally and have like a
label in the attribute data and then
just point at the data and say your
label is whatever is in attribute name
or attribute label right all options
um
and then we can do things like say like
okay any nodes that aren't people let's
make them smaller and make the text big
and we'll sort of have like that view
right
um awesome so we can do that and then
lastly we dumped in a little uh node
color style sheet so this is doing the
same sort of logic we did before to make
the the node color list for Network X
where we're going through finding the
unique values and then we're going to be
uh mapping those mapping those on and
writing a bunch of rules into our style
sheet for that fantastic okay the last
piece which is also lots of information
here we want to set up a cyto layout so
here we're using
uh Coast which is a spring layout
because we've been doing Springs the
whole time but there's a list of
different ones you can pick from from
the cytoscape site and then there's a
bunch of uh initialization parameters
for here the key ones that I think
matter is no doubt relapse so that's uh
saying like how close nodes are allowed
to be to each other before like they're
being repulsed
um the other one uh node repulsion kind
of does the same thing
um
no Dimension include labels means that
all the labels we're going to display
for our nodes should be included in the
bounding box for the node so this will
give more space it also potentially will
make the graph kind of big and wonky if
you have big names because now the node
appears really large
um and then number of iterations will
just uh be how many times the physics
engine runs over and over again
fantastic so now we can Define our app
we can give it a nice little dark theme
and then
if we want to we can start to add in
attribute drop downs I don't think we'll
have time to like entirely Implement
these so I'll kind of skim over it but
right our layout for our app is just
going to be a cytoscape object into it
we're going to Define our layout this
will stay the same
um
we're going to say uh well style it so
that it takes up some space we pass in
our elements and here we decided that
the element should include these
attributes language country right this
is easy now to tweak and rerun and then
the style sheet and we said the style
sheet should be theme dark and then we
should color nodes by country okay so
now we have all the pieces we need the
rest of this is some bootstrap and uh
tossing it in but we should be now ready
to run this and take a look
um
cool so this was what we kind of
promised we do it's the same view we
would have had in plotly right but now
we can come in and explore the plot a
bit more our edges have names and labels
I can see things like
um I don't know
I guess the people didn't have labels in
our implementation here but this person
code Scala and typescript and they're
blue which would mean they're on a
certain team
and we can uh sort of explore this we
can change the size of all these things
like I mentioned but this is our nice
interactive plot what we won't have time
to get into is exploring all of the
different callbacks that we can do on
the graph but this is the fundamentals
that we need in order to visualize and
then explore our graph in dash cytoscape
right
um
the the idea being
um what we could do is take these drop
down attributes and bind these to
through pretty simple callbacks bind
these to the inputs for our generate
elements and for our style sheet right
so right now that's happening at page
load time in the elements and style
sheet inputs to the to the graph but
these are also easy to add in uh as
callbacks because here we have a cyto
layout with a certain Network and all we
need to do is make a callback that's
changing Network and then the style
sheet or network the elements and we can
do that whenever we're toggling our drop
downs so that will make it nice and easy
for us to add in a bunch of attributes
redraw the graph and then see how those
connections work as well as we could
toggle like what colors are being used
to draw that and so I'm thinking we have
all the pieces we need throughout the
last couple notebooks for you to
implement that which is exciting
um
and and that is like the core pieces of
what we want to do in the graph
um awesome that is everything I wanted
to talk about today thanks for coming
along on the trip
um and yeah if you weren't following
along which is fine uh it's all up on my
GitHub and the link is in the pi data
schedule so definitely check that out
does anyone have like quick questions or
anything at the end if not I'll talk for
like one more minute about uh
um yeah so I think Dash inside Escape is
a really powerful way to take uh the
analysis you're already doing in Python
and make a really functional user
interface for it
um
it's a I think adding in this bootstrap
element as well can give it a nice
pretty view without a lot of effort but
you don't need to do this as well it
does cloud your code up a bit adding in
more and more pieces
um but but really this is a powerful way
to expose this to other people uh so
yeah the link to the running app is also
available I deployed it with Google app
engine it was pretty easy took seven or
eight minutes which is exciting
um yeah yeah again just thanks for
everyone for coming out it's been fun
um enjoy the rest of your day
thank you
[Applause]